how did jerry find out about the uh uh
tension right between you and the naked
cowboy
um well what i heard was sharon houston
a comic from um la
uh she she works for it she said that
jerry wanted to have
some comics on
so she they remember me from
[Laughter]
[Music]
jeremy
are you trying to sit here yeah yeah of
course no sit down yeah yeah whatever
you want you can sit there jerry
welcome jerry springer is here
judge jerry thanks guys has arrived
it's the ghost of judge jerry's past yes
here on uh yes what a great show it was
it was a great show she was singing your
praises about how fair you were and uh
how good you treated her
jerry
your staff loves you so much whether
it's ashley or patrice or sharon houston
they love you
well that's that's them all i guess we
ought to pay them
and that's what i said i said i bet he
pays them well yeah that's no it's
because you paid me well yeah
[Laughter]
i'll have to speak to the accountant
jerry of course you remember sandy kane
from the uh from the case of the naked
cowboy versus the naked cowgirls yeah
that you had who had the right to
to be in times square yeah you know it's
it i feel like some at some point judge
jerry
took no you didn't have them on judge
jerry uh did take a turn into more kind
of suiting towards the old
jerry springer show and that's when we
found our friend yeah sandy kane
involved
it probably was inevitable that those
were the cases that would find me yeah
they they find you now right they kind
of follow you yeah i mean they're suits
that are filed so yeah oh they are yeah
yeah you filed it didn't you
no
oh the other guy oh yeah
the other party filed it yeah
yeah
the naked cowboy filed a suit
oh yeah i mean some coins
[Laughter]
that's why you're in court yeah no but i
thought it was all made up like no
oh no oh good i have a new lawsuit
now jerry let me ask you are you a
lawyer did you go you didn't go to law
school i graduated right question uh and
when you what kind of law did you want
to do did you want to be a prosecutor i
did i i was not a prosecutor i was a
defense attorney you are
yeah yeah i practiced for you oh okay um
it's i had i wanted to be a lawyer when
i was in high school but then i'm not
doing it
yeah what high school
that or law yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
why they said yeah
high school
yeah were you were you like in court
litigator yeah were you good at it a
trial attorney i'm sure he was
it's all about talking
yeah i can talk yeah yeah yeah
hey how you doing
yeah in new york yeah yeah in queens
yeah do you remember we were talking
about times square sam and i watched
that special about the the torso killer
in times square do you remember that it
was in the 70s when there was a guy
killing girls in uh
in times square
i
off the top of my head i don't
i mean
this morning when i got up i said i
wonder whatever happened to that guy
it yeah a netflix documentary just i've
never heard of him before and they just
did a like a five-part series in about
the 70s in times square and it's uh what
do you think 70s i was uh i was already
in cincinnati oh you are okay yeah yeah
so when you're uh uh
when you're
when you were becoming a lawyer
is the thing like i want to be in the
courtroom i want to be trying cases like
that or is it like is it the research
part the truth the truth is uh i
went into law because well my parents
said you know you choose you want to be
a doctor or a lawyer and you would go
either to med school or law school
and i was interested in politics i was
active in the end in the civil rights
movement in the anti-war movement in the
60s i was your basic hippie
and uh so i wasn't thinking about a
career at all i just
uh
my first job out of law school was with
bobby kennedy and then when he was
killed i took a job with a law firm in
cincinnati and immediately got into
politics there and
spent 10 years on city council and being
mayor of cincinnati would you move for
robert kennedy what'd you do for robert
kennedy well it was not it's only a few
months because of what happened sure but
uh in 1968 i was working
seven um states on the college campuses
to try to get the mccarthy kids to
switch over to bobby for the convention
because at that time
the democratic party was split johnson
was the president he was going to run
for re-election
and because of the war many of us did
not want him to run for reelection
because we were blaming him for
expanding the war
and um
gene mccarthy the senator from
minnesota was the first one to get into
the race
and then after he did well in new
hampshire bobby kennedy
decide in fact it was exactly 54 years
ago today
march 16 1968 that bobby kennedy
announced for president oh wow that was
the beginning of an 85 day campaign wow
i was because this morning i got up and
i said march 16th what happened then wow
and i remember that was it and uh so
yeah that that's what's the beginning of
the short-lived campaign and it
it was an incredible we've never had
a year like
1968 where you know there's obviously
there was a lot of controversy going on
with trump and all that there's no
question
uh but in terms of the country just
blowing up 1968 was the year i mean that
was the year
of vietnam that was the year that martin
luther king was assassinated
uh then bobby kennedy uh two months
later was assassinated then they had the
riots in chicago at the democratic
convention and then
jfk was it also feels like it was very
unprecedented in 1968 right like when
you see it feels like now the idea of
a lot of everything happening all at
once and people being angry all the time
this is something that has been kind of
simmering for years and years and years
in 1968 like that's not that wasn't the
norm right right that's true and uh
but it both
years and certainly now did they kill
marilyn monroe you think who did did you
because they were supposed to be bobby
kennedy peter law
were you involved in lessons
[Laughter]
marilyn i can't see you tonight
all right
what do you think sandy what do you
think no i i think it's an interesting
case because it keeps coming back man
and i love marilyn monroe and i'm
wondering because she was she was
[ __ ] all bobby and and john
and she was going to expose them that
they that she had sex with them and
ruined the campaign that you're talking
about i love the idea that uh
jerry works for them for like as a kid
for like a couple of months and they're
like we gotta tell you something first
we had her she's the reason she's gone
you know what we did right no no did you
get to meet bobby kennedy yeah oh that's
great yeah what was he like huh he he
was he was wonderful
yeah yeah he was other than my dad he
was the biggest
political influence on my life in terms
of
what my politics are etc do you think
there still are uh
politicians
like that in the sense that like are
there people now
that you think people could be inspired
by or has it become such a
sort of surprise but it's it's so
different today
in other words
there's
well strangely enough
one of the people who i disagree with on
virtually every issue that ever came up
but i certainly admire her
her courage and her
integrity um liz cheney
um but you don't find many people like
that that are literally willing
anymore to to put country before their
party
and so
here she has literally
side you know destroyed at least
temporarily her political career by
going against trump which
was the appropriate thing to do
and uh she's paying a price for it
because you know the party's kicking her
out basically didn't tulsi gabbard do
that too kind of like not exactly what
the democrats wanted her to do like on
the other end yeah yeah yeah yeah but it
there also it also matters what you're
standing up for
you know and in 1968 that was done
here you had lyndon johnson who was the
democratic you know our president and
who won in a landslide in 1964
and he was our president and here we
were which was unheard of at the time
standing up
to try and
defeat him in the primaries for his
re-election in other words we
put
we were putting in our
view country before party so even though
he's our president we don't want him
running again and we're going to
challenge him
and that's basically what liz cheney's
doing that you know this is america you
can't have
you know she's basically saying you
can't have someone like trump as your
president yeah i don't want to go what
about kathy the the governor of new york
do you like her you think she's doing a
good job well from from a distance
because i'm not living here now
um oh stanford connecticut you live no
uh sarasota florida
i do the show in connecticut yes they
don't do it in his house
you don't have a court room in your
house i'm actually i'm living right
behind the bench there
but you have a sleeping bag underneath
no but you're always on so i i thought
yeah you know you're always on
you pre-taped some of the shows right
why sarasota sarasota why
[Laughter]
nothing it's not personal yes i don't
like his politics
okay
and the censorship which they just
passed this week which which is amazing
um
that you're um you're not allowed either
in your workplace
or in schools
uh you're not allowed to um
talk about racism
white supremacy
and prejudice and you're not allowed
good idea though no no i mean
[Laughter]
jerry are you allowed to learn about our
history
oh no the history yes that's
yeah see i'd rather have the future not
the history
no i you know what you and me we have
more history than a future
that's a good one sandy you got to give
it to jerry on that one
men two points for jerry make more money
to me that's what all you guys are yeah
sarasota what the [ __ ] sorry
why sarasota
do you ever do you think sometimes to
yourself right like you have all these
great ideas and like this is what
inspires you clearly this is what gets
your brains going you like this and this
is the life this is the world that you
wanted to get into
when you're sitting there on the judge's
bench right
you're watching
sandy kane and the naked cowboy and his
naked cow wife bickering over who can be
in times square do you ever think to
yourself
i was meant to do more yeah uh well in
fairness not all the cases are like that
so well i watched one other one and our
friend mike beauchetti was being sued by
a list of you both of your friends
yeah
aaron and gino weren't they
yeah those are the ones we call that's
what i i wondered about myself actually
when i was like should i know
this many people that are on judge jerry
no actually no you went for comics
that's what sharon said yeah that jerry
jerry wants comics on the show to do you
make it more more fun interesting yeah
yeah interesting cases yes i've always
kept
uh my
career separate from my politics
clearly because you ruined both if you
try to mix it in otherwise for 27 years
doing the crazy show yeah um
i never once talked politics on the show
but because it would one my politics
wouldn't be taken seriously if i did it
on the show and secondly it would ruin
the show because people aren't turning
onto the show to hear what my political
views are do you think like keep it
separate are you able to be friends with
people like because sam and i are very
opposite like you know i'm very liberal
and he's like almost like a
don't discuss evolution in schools
religious conservatives
yeah that's not true
i like that i don't think you should
i'll tell you why this is
my opinion
no because i think
this might not you know
i think that a lot of times if there's a
gay teacher
that sometimes they try to make people
gay and then no gays are like
not that i don't like gays i love gay
people and no i think
it's just that um i think
that's your publicist
[Laughter]
i like that
[Laughter]
i'm on the air now can i call you back
hi i'm actually on a radio show now i'll
call you back jim and sam in the house
folks
[ __ ]
okay what isn't that funny that's
hilarious
i know where you are get out of the room
yes that sound is coming from inside the
studio i apologize no no not at all i'm
going to turn this
it was actually uh comedically the best
thing that could have happened what's
sandy what you were saying
okay
i think i think what do you think
[Laughter]
i don't think people come on you're not
thinking
you just said um i never mix politics
with the show
same thing a teacher has their own
opinions on whether they're gay or not
don't
talk to the kids about it just you know
just be a teacher teach
what should they teach
whatever the [ __ ] they're teaching but
well that's what part part part
part of an education
is to not just teach how to add and how
to subtract part of an education is to
get a young person ready for the world
that they're going into
so what you learn for example the reason
we had integration in the first place is
you're going to live in a multicultural
world that is reality america is a
multicultural nation you have to learn
and it's what our declaration of
independence is about all men are
created equal etc
the statue of liberty give me you're
tired you're hungry you're poor so we
have to learn and our children have to
learn and that's how we raise them
to never judge someone
by what they are
you only judge people based on what they
do
so you don't judge a person because they
are of a particular race of a particular
religion right of a particular sexual
orientation you don't judge people like
that but you have to so we teach our
kids
to understand other people to be kind
you know there ought to be just one rule
that we have
and that is be kind
and if you were current we wouldn't pass
the laws we wouldn't pass the laws we
have imagine if legislators when they
pass legislation
they have to at the bottom answer the
question and what you just passed is
that kind
are you being kind to gay people are you
being kind to african americans are you
being kind to women are you being kind
you know just why do we pass laws that
make someone feel bad that's i
appreciate that and i wish you would
explain that to someone across the table
here
i'm being mischaracterized this morning
we had to check before i came in
yeah but be a teacher don't
because you're gay don't you try to
manipulate kids to be gay and i think
that what if you had a teacher that was
that heterosexual should we not have
teachers who are heterosexual no i think
why it's dangerous aren't they making
kids straight yeah no i i think it
should be kept out of the classroom just
teach whatever you're teaching and
you're teaching social studies if you're
teaching american history
we have to know what we have done to
people in this country so that this next
generation
can grow up to fix some of the problems
let's face it younger people today
are far more open-minded
you know when when i was a kid and we
started to have television a husband and
wife had to be in separate beds
yeah right
you had you never had i love lucy yeah
you never had an african-american
you know you didn't have
african-americans on shows with white
people unless they wear the butler
unless they were you know
it's sam hold your applause
i'm being mischaracterized
and now the white people are the butlers
and you don't like that standard it's
wrong
if that's your job that's your job